democratic senator sheldon whitehouse is
under fire after being questioned on his
family's decades-long membership
to an all-white beach club in rhode
island when pressed on this white house
defended his membership by saying this
it's a long tradition in rhode island
and there are many of them
and uh i think we just need to work our
way through the issues thank you
this this this is one of your fighters
for social justice and racial equity
this is this is what you what you get
did he just use the long tradition
defense for his
all-white club as a woke democrat
whose wife is is on the board and could
change the policies
okay i'm going to steal from our
colleague kennedy it sounds like he's a
senator white privilege
instead who has had plenty he was
criticized about this
in 2006 when he first ran for the senate
and said he would disavow it
turns out he likes his little club with
all all the white folks
if he wanted to change it he could have
a long time ago rules for thee
not for me he he likes his uh that
moment
very symbolic of the racial debate going
on across this country in every aspect
last topic i'm up against the clock just
a long tradition
and this is my favorite one democratic
representative donald payne highlighted
a major security threat during a recent
congressional homeland security meeting
the threat is him in boxer's pain is
seen getting up during the remote
meeting where he proceeds to flaunt his
belly on screen
and congresswoman kat kamik's reaction
says it all
as she sees that gut shot i i don't even
know if it's fair to ask me
for me to ask a guy here who's basically
showing his chest hair
if you and and he met in the middle
there would be like one button done his
at the bottom his belly yours at the top
showing anything you need for me uh you
don't want me to stand up right now
either will be a bad scene
okay anyone who's doing this business
though you don't stand up
and you always double click on the leave
meeting button because if you leave that
thing
on you're in big trouble i mean this is
old people leaving
using zoom and the serious point is why
are they still doing zoom calls for
congress like we've got entire nba games
packed
and these folks can't show up you did
another button down you just took
another button down by the way the zoom
lesson for you
what you were talking about didn't we
all learn the zoom lesson with jeffrey
toobin
come on i mean jeffrey tubin is the
ultimate cautionary tale
i'm gonna see you later this week okay
man yes it's true thanks for doing this
all right brother
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else